what Americans think of national
security they tend to think in terms of
military threats but national security
is also question of maintaining a
nation's way of life whether people have
the jobs and the goods that they're
accustomed to increasingly we have asked
that question in the context of
international trade many of the goods
that we buy come from abroad each day
about 6 million containers of the kind
that you can see behind me arrived in
the United States from other countries
carrying everything from television sets
to clothes to toys you name it that
globalized economy has turned out to be
both the challenge and an opportunity
for the United States the United States
has important comparative advantages we
have a vibrant tech sector and we have
the most fertile agricultural sector in
the world those two sectors true
international trade have generated
millions of American jobs but we also
have comparative disadvantages the wage
scale in the United States is much
higher than it is in countries like
China and India in Guatemala that means
that those Goods often can be produced
more cheaply abroad that's good for
consumers we pay less for the goods we
buy as a result but it also means that
millions of American jobs have been lost
to foreign firms the fact that global
trade involves winners and losers has
made it one of the most important policy
issues of our time